depuis le 31 octobre la seule à nice
premium a ouvert ses portes au cinéma
cgr une salle qui a dû passer par la
case travaux avec un budget d'un million
d'euros un coût nécessaire pour rendre
cette salle plus attractive
donc voilà comment se présente la salle
donc que les fauteuils en cuir
inclinable numérotées donc ce qui vous
permet de réserver à l'avancé notamment
maintenant si vous voulez par exemple
réserver pour star wars qui a lieu en
décembre pouvez déjà réserver votre
place et vous aurez votre place du
groupe sera attitré
en plus de ça vous avez donc une
personne un agent d'accueil qui est
dédié à la salle qui vous accueille dans
la salle donc pour vous placer ce sera à
toutes les séances vraiment donc comme
ça au moins vous serez pas perdu
star wars épisode 9 la reine des neiges
2 ou encore doumandji next level seront
diffusés dans cette salle un peu
particulière une immersion dans le film
avec des écrans sur les côtés de la
salle et des spots derrière les
spectateurs pour créer une ambiance
visuelle n'y a pas de salle premium en
yvelines ça change en fait vous vivez
vraiment une véritable expérience comme
on l'a dit immersif cinéma expérience
c'est vraiment pour être en immersion
quelque chose voilà vous vivez le film
notamment au niveau de l'image du son et
des panneaux a ici merci vraiment vous
êtes dans le film et ça apporte quelque
chose pour voir un film dans cette salle
il faut compter entre 2 et 4 euros de
plus que pour un film ou dans une salle
normale en ce qui nous concerne le
rapport qualité prix non je suis joueur
pour découvrir aujourd'hui la première
fois ça dépendrait du film mais oui pour
être un peu comme à la maison
un rapport qualité prix qui divise le
cinéma cgr vise un public jeune
notamment avec les films qui seront
bientôt à l affiche dans cette nouvelle
salle